we have massive trade deficits with
almost every country we will straighten
that out we are actually working on
cutting tariffs and making it all very
fair for both countries we've made a lot
of progress it could be that NAFTA will
be a different form it could be with
Canada with Mexico one on one much
simpler agreement much easier to do well
trade the big talk at the g7 summit up
in Canada they are meeting with Canadian
Prime Minister Trudeau just short time
ago the president meeting with the
French president macro who spoke earlier
about the tariffs that the u.s. is
imposing specifically on steel and
aluminum reform on gate duty easy the
foundation which has been used to
justify these measures in attempt to
present them as according to
international commercial law there's an
argument of national security
nobody would think that the imports of
steel of aluminum coming from Canada
from France or other European countries
are of threatening nature so where do we
go from here on the g7 and what's coming
out of it let's bring in our panel byron
york chief political correspondent of
The Washington Examiner Charles Lane the
opinion writer for The Washington Post
and Tom Bevin RealClearPolitics
co-founder and president
all right Byron obviously there are a
number of leaders up there who have a
problem with how the president is
dealing with the tariff situation but
they're they're talking it through it
seems they are you know I think the
first thing to note about this summit is
that it just says the president seems
totally focused on North Korea he's
going to Canada late he's leaving early
this is not something that he seems
totally focused on but the the bigger
thing is the president is simply
incapable of engaging in the kind of
diplomatic niceties that you have to
deal with they have to do at these
meetings they normally govern these
meetings he is the anti diplomat last
year he was pushing on NATO to
contribute more to their own defense now
he's pushing other countries on trade to
give the United States a better deal his
theme is always that other countries are
taking advantage of
big rich United States and in the end
just as in NATO he will get a little bit
of what he's asking for you know and the
other thing Chuck is he's stirring the
pot before leaving for this summit he
said this about having Russia back in I
have been Russia's worst nightmare with
that being said Russia should be in this
meeting why are we having a meeting
without Russia being in the meeting
whether you like it or not and it may
not be politically correct but we have a
world to run we should have Russia at
the negotiating table Chuck there's so
much to comment on in that one little
statement Russia was cast out of what
was then the g8 in punishment for an
egregious violation of international law
that is the seizure of Crimea in 2014
most recently they violated
international law again by attempting to
assassinate two people within Britain
and the United States itself
participated in collective retaliation
sanctions based on that so for the
President to sound this note of urgency
that we got to get Russia back in the
room so we can run the world together is
just at odds with all of that recent
history and I'm sure must have been very
very puzzling and dismaying to these
traditional Western allies who are
trying to figure out exactly what it is
he is driving at to go back to something
Byron said which is he doesn't go in for
diplomatic niceties I think that's true
and I think in some cases that can be
useful the problem is you'd have to have
a bottom line at some point and I think
what these other countries find so
baffling and ultimately frustrating is
he is setting up a situation in which
the only way they can give him what he
wants at the end is to be humiliated by
him in other words he's making these
open-ended demands in such a tone that
the only way to say yes is to accept
your own humiliation and I'm not sure
that's gonna lead anywhere Tom well I
think Chuck and Byron are both right
look Trump one of the things that people
liked about Trump is the fact that he's
a fighter and
or not there is widespread agreement I
think on the fact that some of these
trade deals actually are unfair to the
United States even business leaders will
tell you that and they need to be
recalibrated renegotiated the problem is
a lot of folks have a they have an issue
with with the style in which Trump is
doing it and some of the tactics that
he's using that he's just using tariffs
as a bludgeon so so that's part of the
problem he is certainly now in full
honey badger mode he is attacking
everybody and it is we'll see where that
ends up leading I mean I think he will
end up getting something and and be able
to declare some sort of victory but he
is certainly I think put the rest of the
world on notice that he is not messing
around when it comes to renegotiating
these trade deals yeah I like that
full honey badger mode okay you know he
is the biggest figure there as far as
making headlines but also look at the
GDP of these countries and you compare
them collectively they don't add up to
what the GDP of the United States is so
that tells you a little bit about how
this is all going down Byron it does
because everything the United States
does just has has greater emphasis than
anything else so I drop it to here again
it's going to come away with something
added this the talk he did today about
renegotiating NAFTA so it would not be a
North American agreement it'd be a
one-on-one agreement between the United
States and Canada or between the United
States and Mexico shows that he's
actually thinking about fundamentally
restructuring some of these agreements
and because of those GDP figures you
just showed the other countries don't
have any other choice but to negotiate
with him so this negotiation is ongoing
but he's getting ready for another one
we're gonna talk about that in the
Friday lightning round Chuck but there's
a lot of big moments for this president
at this time yes and just to come back
to what Byron said no other choice in
other words yes the United States has
tremendous leverage were the biggest
economy in the world by far at the end
of the day they have to deal with us but
what's so concerning about this and
what's so different about it that had
not been the basis upon which we dealt
with these particular country
is overtime that you have no choice it
had been much more a question of mutual
interest mutual values and this is
really I think what they find so
baffling and disturbing it's a
revolutionary change it's not just tonal
and it's it's unpredictable going
forward